if your life depended on it what
gymnastics event Would You Bet Your Life
that you could do so you got tumbling
you got the Rings the pommel horse the
balance beam I'll tell you what I
wouldn't do the uneven bars this is not
a shot in hell I wouldn't crack my skull
open you would break that I like to
think I'd be able to but then I know the
first attempt of going from that bar to
that bar it's over I would do the
parallel bars because that's like dips I
could do a lot of dips what is your best
thing you can do for push-ups I could
probably I also weigh 250 pounds so
pull-ups I could do probably 15 which is
great because as a fat kid I did zero
and it was devastating yeah you did zero
pull-ups it took you half an hour to run
the 600 effect
what are you doing where are your
parents